[Music]
almost always the things that trigger us
are the things we're struggling with
okay so if you're complaining that
nobody's listening to you how good are
you at listening if you complain that
nobody values you how good are you at
valuing others I'm a great believer that
we should help people who are struggling
with the things that we're struggling
with you know I think this is the core
of service you know like the 12th step
of Alcoholics Anonymous is to help
another alcoholic service think about
your personal relationships my
girlfriend never listens to me well when
was the last time you sat and were good
at listening to your girlfriend if you
start by taking accountability does
something remarkable my girlfriend and I
had a fight the other day and I
interrupted I said okay new rules we're
going to flip the script cuz you're
telling me everything you're doing right
and everything I'm doing wrong and by
the way I'm telling you everything I'm
doing right and that you're doing wrong
so let's just interrupt this and flip
the script I'm going to tell you
everything I'm doing wrong and
everything you're doing right and then I
want you to do the same and we did I
started saying all right I got this
wrong and you really you really nailed
this and then she said that we took
turns and it was absolutely remarkable
wow if you've been following me a while
you know that I I've been drinking ag1
all year no matter where I go or what I
do if I'm at the racetrack if I'm in
Europe for six weeks no matter what I'm
drinking ag1 every single morning when I
started drinking ag1 daily what I
noticed was that my gut health improved
I could eat so many different foods
without it bothering me my skin has
gotten better my hair is healthier so
many functions that everybody wants to
get better got better it's so awesome
and I've been bragging about it so much
that my friends and my family have also
started taking it and they love it as
well ag1 is the supplement that I trust
to support my body's daily needs and
that's why we have been partners for so
long if you want to take ownership of
your health it starts with ag1 try ag1
and get a free one-year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 plus five free ag1 travel
packs with your first purchase go to
drink ag1 /pret intense that's drink
a1.com Prett intense check it out
ultimately I want to know how people can
all be successful and the real question
is can they all be and what does that
actually look like do you think that
knowing who you are is foundational to
being successful it depends on how you
define success well I guess we got to
start there then the simple answer would
be no I don't think it's foundational
for being successful I think there are a
lot of people who are con what we would
consider conventional successful without
knowing who they are is that success
lasting are they happy are they having
an outsized impact beyond the success
that they've achieved and I think to to
to accomplish those things then knowing
who you are becomes foundational but
simply a level of accomplishment not
necessarily do you feel like you know
who you are I do and I think that's
always an ongoing thing right this is an
evolution but there can be a point in
our life where that really shifts so I
think a lot of people quote unquote find
themselves there's no right way I think
some people find themselves after
tragedy I think a lot of people find
themselves when thrust into struggle
post September 11th I think a lot of
people sort of reevaluated their careers
post you know uh uh Co I think a lot of
people reevaluate when you when you
suffer loss it it I think those things
and struggle those things are um they
force you to reconcile with what's
really important and and some people who
are truly tested they find they find an
inner strength they didn't know that
they had um but those aren't the only
ways you don't have to go through
struggle or loss to to learn who you are
I mean um that was my story I did go
through a hardship for me to really have
the epiphany of the path that I was on
um but um but I I mean this is what I've
I've attempted to do which is once I've
learned once I learned how to help
people find their why this Foundation of
what drives them the the this this inner
flame that inspires um um you can go
through a relatively simple process to
uncover that um I I don't think
discovering who you are is actually the
difficult part um that can come
relatively easily through difficulty
through a process through an interview
process through a workbook like you know
again there's I think that's I think
that's actually not the difficult part
the challenge I think it's what you do
with it once you have it you know
learning your why is a tool that's why
the book is called start with why I feel
like for people to get to the point
where they even ask that and want to
find that I don't think that's that easy
the discovery of it learning what it is
is pretty easy you know um you can learn
your why in a couple hours you know
right um but you said it which is which
is people are so heads down following
the path in the grind on the on the
hamster wheel whatever you know rodent
driven metaphor you want to use they
don't ever ask themselves the question
who am I why am I doing this MH why
should anyone care why did I get out of
bed this morning and you usually get the
cuz I have to or that's the that's the
game I have to play or for my family or
I got to make a living but to truly be
able to answer that question you're
right I think a lot of people don't
don't spend a lot of time and that's why
I say struggle is a big part of it
because usually they have to hit a wall
to then want to ask the question but you
don't have to wait for that wall people
can ask that question anytime but you're
right I think asking the question is the
is the is the hard part um finding the
answer is relative easy and then what
you do with the answer then becomes the
real the real work of one's life why
does it take people so long what is it
that holds them back or what is it that
slows them down to getting out of the
Rat Race like why why do people just
stay on that hamster wheel of like I go
to work I come home I eat i' go to bed I
get up I think it's for the same reason
that we focus on the Urgent at the
expense of the important you know we
fight the fight in front of us right you
know it's like why is it easy to uh eat
chocolate cake but it's hard to exercise
and eat healthy it's because the
chocolate Cake's right in front of me
and it's super appealing where I
actually have to put in effort to like
go to the gym or say no to the chocolate
cake or eat a salad like like the
healthy stuff actually takes more effort
eating the chocolate C is is is easy so
I think showing up and being in the rat
race is easier every day go to work boss
gives an instruction follow the
instructions do as you're told get a
promotion push push push compete compete
you know I I just think it's it's it's
more tangible and more immediate what
you and I are talking about is like how
to be healthy like well that requires
being able to understand things that are
sometimes amorphous or ethereal and it's
about planning ahead and it's about
saving money versus spending money I
mean like all these analogies it's much
easier to spend money than it is to save
money um um because there's instant
gratification so I think the rat race
provides instant gratification that's
what it's designed to do that's we have
annual B bonus structures instant
gratification you know it's almost like
they breadcrumb there's like breadcrumbs
of uh reward along the way to to sort of
just be satiating enough to keep you
going but not truly inspired to me
that's that's kind of what happens when
there's magic and Alchemy with someone
in their life is they become inspired I
think that's well put which is it's
satisfying but not inspiring right it
doesn't mean it's bad right like it like
I don't I think I I think we often say
when somebody's in the rat race that
everybody's working around zombie and
depressed that's not true at all it can
be fun and I can like my colleagues and
I can enjoy my work and I can be
satisfied with the work that I do and
get the money have but do I consider
myself deeply inspired and fulfilled no
you know do I feel like I'm working for
something bigger than myself no you know
but who wants to live a life just being
satisfied that's like how are you I'm
fine how's work it's fine like there's
nothing it's fine is perfectly adequate
but it's just fine the conversation what
I want to f figure out is if everyone is
really meant to be great or Meant To Be
Inspired or meant to like get Beyond
satisfied or if there's just such a
scale of it such a there's just such a
such a range of it that it's like my my
answers may surprise you which is I
don't believe that I don't believe that
it's not for us to decide how someone
else should live their life you know I I
have found for me that starting with why
and learning my purpose and trying to
build a career in a life based on that
purpose has been IM immensely rewarding
for me and for all those who want that I
work very hard to share ideas and tools
that will help them on that Journey but
if someone is not interested in it I've
never made any effort to try and
convince them you know when I had I've
happened many times where somebody will
say to me um I think you're wrong I
think this is pointless and I don't
think you really understand how the
world works and my answer is okay so
don't do it like I'm not going to stand
here and convince you that I'm right and
you're wrong wrong like the decisions
you make for your life are right for you
the decisions I've made for my life are
right for me and for other people who
are curious about some of the things
that I have to share I'm I'm all I'm
open and giving and willing to to share
whatever it is you want to know and if
you think what I have is ridiculous or
stupid or naive that's okay like I'm
cool with that too so I I'm I'm not here
to PE tell people they should do
something I try and think of my work as
an invitation which is if this is
something that you find appealing come
on over you know um and if it's
unappealing then then I genuinely want
you to find joy in whatever Journey
you're on and if you change your mind
later I'll still be here with the work
that you do the inspiration that you
create the through experience and
awareness what do you hope that people
learn from you it's a good question what
do I hope they learn from me are you
trying to teach is maybe the first
question what are yeah I know I'm a
preacher abely for sure I'm sharing a
gospel I mean what I hope they learn
from me at thee at the core is not
actually
purpose the core it's
cooperation at the the core of all of my
work is it's not it's not about you you
know and I'm I'm very fond of saying
that there's an entire section of the
Bookshop called self-help but there's no
section in the Bookshop called help
others and if you so true and if you
look at anybody who ever accomplished
anything in this world of any kind of
value whatsoever ever even if it's
selfish right they didn't do it alone
right none of us nothing that you
accomplished in your life you do alone
nothing that I've accomplished in my
life to do I do alone and when people
start telling you what they did to be
successful I mean they think that's the
worst place to start like let me tell
you what what I I couldn't have done
without love support and people taking
bets on me you know um so uh I I think
my work is fundamentally about how do
you show up for other people my my work
is fundamentally about service um and
all of my work whether it's start with Y
or Leaders Eat Last or the infinite game
or any other idea I put out in any sort
of other media not just books
fundamentally what you'll find is the
common threat is about
service and it's why I'm attracted and
Drawn to people of
service why is it that there's a need
for that you'd think that in a planet of
8 billion people we understand we don't
do it alone but what makes someone what
is it about someone's personality that
makes them not in the mode of Cooper
operation or service others we get the
behavior we reward right um and I think
that if you look at the incentive
structures whether it's bonus packages
whether it's how we reward people with
our Fame and adoration and who we follow
who we look up to we've over indexed I
think as a nation the rugged individual
the malbro man you know that we've
heroized individuals you know and CEOs
and celebrities we started to to see
this pattern really really expedite you
know this sort of uh me before we um
it's probably started in the late 70s
but really gain momentum in the 80s and
90s where we started to see changes in
business for example Jack Welch the CEO
of GE was really the poster child for
like short-termism and pitting your
people against each other and individual
rewards remember if you go back to the
second world war there were more young
men who committed suicide because they
didn't get drafted for than those who
did yes that the call to service was so
powerful that not getting called to
serve was more traumatic it's not like
these things happen overnight you know
all these young young men come back from
second world war they've lived through
the Great Depression they've lived
through the second world war and they
realize when they've come back from war
that they've really had their youth
stolen from them and they've they've
either struggled or given their lives to
things bigger than themselves and
legitimately they come back and say what
what about me m and so the 1950s you
start to see this very slow transition
of people hunkering down and starting to
and we see household incomes and and and
and household wealth in the United
States
Skyrocket um and then you get to the
1960s and you sort of have the hippie
movement in the United States well you
have to remember you can't have a hippie
movement without wealthy parents right
your parents have to be rich for you to
not work okay you go chill at Woodstock
for a week you need to have I me you got
you got to have means right so there's
no there's no hippie movements in poor
Nations because you kind of for not to
work you know you can't afford to drop
out right so we're starting to see what
happens when household incomes go up um
and then you start to see by the time
the 1970s show up and you have um
economists like Milton Friedman who
theorize that the purpose of work is
simply to to maximize profit within the
bounds of the rules no mention of Ethics
or service or contribution and we start
to see a redefining of business and um
you know there were no such thing as
mass layoffs to balance the books prior
to the 1980s it actually didn't exist
right existentially sure like our
company's going bankrupt we have to have
layoffs absolutely but there was no such
thing as we're announcing a round of
layoffs because we missed our arbitrary
projections like we're profitable but
not as profitable as we promis so you
lose your job that did not exist in the
United States prior to the 1980s and so
we start to see this rise of selfishness
putting the company before the economy
putting the company my individual
performance we see the rise of uh of of
of selfish incentive structures where we
now um compensate Prof Prof Executives
based on the price of the stock price
not how well the company is doing think
about that for a second you don't get a
bonus based on how well the company is
doing you get a bonus based on how good
the stock price is so for example if the
company announces similar if the no if
the company announces huge investment in
R&D in research and development oh then
the bottom line the stop price often
goes down right now that's a very good
investment in the future that is right
for the company that's a long term so
everybody's work working shortterm
instead of longterm start shortening and
shortening our sort exactly and so and
when the company announces Mass layoffs
the stock price goes up right right
that's screwed up right right right this
is right so you start to see a
shortening of time Horizons and and and
an exaggeration of me before we and so
when you so this is the very long-winded
qu answer to your question why should
why like it's embarrassing that I have a
career there should be no demand for my
work here I'm talking about service
cooperation you know trust like there
should be should be like more
foundational morals that we don't you
should have to say it I shouldn't have a
career you know um um but the fact that
my work resonates with people is because
they feel like something's missing or
there's a demand for this stuff exactly
so I you know we can we can commiserate
and say oh woe is us that that we found
ourselves this this is the hand we're
dealt like this is where we are this is
where we find ourselves it is what it is
let's focus on where we're going and how
to reverse the trend that we're on in my
opinion these things kind of just keep
coming full circle like I have this idea
as sort of proba idea how it's like oh
just we just need to get away and start
over and start a commune and get all
your friends and have a great time and
everything's kosher and everything is
happy and then everybody will want to
come and then it'll get really popular
and then there'll be a lot of people and
then all of a sudden you're going to
need some rules probably and then you
might need someone to like be in charge
and then a couple more people and all of
a sudden you end up with some sort of
like like somewh somewhat like a
government again and then like it just
starts all over again and so how do we
what's where's this Loop is this Loop
coming back around do we come back
around to the you know the 30s 20s and
30s when cooperation was normal I'm
assuming 20 30s the 20s I'm not old
enough to remember what the 20s was a
lot of uh speculation and what led to
the Great Depression so do I well then
there's a different question then do you
think that this is sort of just sort of
like winding road or is this something
where we we we make we learn our lessons
and we come back around and then these
certain things transition into another
loop of the same thing does that make
sense the answer is both right of of
course these things are cyclical because
people are idiots and like we we have
short Memories We can't remember and we
always react to the times we're in
capitalism is a good thing but it got a
little bit um Haywire or it started to
where only a small percentage were
really reaping the benefits from a
wealthy nation and we left out everybody
else so people then you see the rise of
populism you know whether it's Donald
Trump or whether it's Bernie Sanders you
know you the rise of a populist movement
because people are raising their hands
and saying wait wait wait wait wait this
is not fair you know what ad Adam Smith
envisioned with capitalism and the
sharing of the wealth of a nation was
supposed to benefit everyone but it
seems to only be benefiting a few I'm
against that and so there's Corrections
and when you know nature abhor a vacuum
nature abhor imbalance and so whenever
you reach a point of imbalance there's a
correction so it's not so that it's
quote unquote naturally a cycle it's
usually what happens is you're on a path
you lose sight of the plot you become to
invested in whatever the short-term
thing is and uh it gets out of balance
and then there's a correction and then
that it swings too far the other way and
then there's a correction it swings too
far this way and there's a correction
and so yes it's cyclical in the sense
that you know we never know where we
never know what right is and what and it
and it's the Frailty of human beings
we're greedy we're ambitious we're
close-minded we're shortsighted you know
we're motivated by short-termism because
dopamine is more powerful than almost
anything whatever system we're and it's
going to get out of balance and then we
correct for it and so this is what
you're calling the pendulum right but to
Simply sit back and say oh it's just a
cycle just wait because we can have
influence as to how long and how violent
the correction is if you wait too long
you're going to have
violent uh Corrections that's what
revolutions are right you waited too
long the system is so out of balance
that that it gets more aggressive do you
think that's where we're at it certainly
feels that way it certainly feels that
way um and so I think for you know what
did Edmund Burke say all that is
required for evil to Triumph is for good
men to do nothing and so if you're going
to do the whole it's just a cycle thing
then um it could be worse before it gets
better and I think that's where um
that's where responsibility sets in I
think to fall back on Cycles is um to to
just call things a cycle is
uh is is choing to be a uh to abdicate
responsibility to be a passive a
passenger on this journey of life and I
would rather be an active participant
and see things get better sooner rather
than simply wait and go through the like
why should we have to go through a
second world war for things to get
better like we could have acted sooner
and avoided the war like things did get
better but my god there was a lot of
death and destruction to get that and I
think we have responsibilities to uh
diminish the amount of damage that takes
place for it to get better how does the
shift actually happen then change starts
at home right I think we're all good at
screaming and yelling who should be
changing you know we hate our
politicians we hate our businesses we
hate this person we hate that person we
blame everybody else and though that may
be true that's not going to change
anything nobody ever changed their
behavior because they were yelled at you
know like nobody nobody ever read a
comment in their Instagram and be like
you know what you're right I am going to
completely change my point of view
because of your comment thank you for
that like said no one ever right um or
when you're screaming in somebody's face
about who you know what you think about
them and what you think they are they
nobody ever said huh good point right I
think change starts at home I think um
you know if you think somebody else is a
bad listener why don't you practice
listening if you think somebody's
closed-minded why don't you practice an
open mind you buy at home you mean
within yourself within within your
sphere influence take self- awareness
and that is not super common no no no so
self the dist self awareness service and
and and when I say starting at home
meaning impact the things that you can
actually impact you know um like your
own Community your own your your own
small world all of our we all of us have
relatively small worlds yeah you know
we've got our friends we've got our
family see the same old people all the
people you intera you know we interact
with the Barista on you know every now
and then like you know our world is the
people that
we you know your kids teachers you know
some colleagues at work that's our world
and most of us no matter how successful
somebody is our worlds are relatively
similar in scope and size
right um and uh um so I I I think that
uh uh change starts at home like be nice
to the Barista like be curious about
somebody's point of view if it's
different than yours learn to listen
learn to give and receive feedback you
know etc etc and what we start to see is
that our politicians and our businesses
will reflect us yeah as I think they do
um they are our a reflection of us so if
we change ourselves if enough of us if
enough of us commit to that the ripples
the ripples just just like it went the
other way like we became selfish and now
we live in a selfish world how important
do you think it is we're talking about
okay go be nice to this person be more
patient here how much of that is
actually starts with not necessarily
doing it for someone outside of yourself
but for yourself be nice to yourself
like look in the mirror and say
something nice to yourself stop being so
judgmental yourself like the actual
reverse self- practice like of the
inward practice and that cuz in my own
experience I find that the more I do
that for myself the it's it's only then
that I can do it for someone else yeah I
think there's some truth to that I don't
think it's the only route but I
definitely think it's a more efficient
and um I think it's no to I was a total
dick to everyone until I started
actually looking at no I'm just kidding
I mean I I just really think that until
you yourself yeah my friend Rick says
you have to practice practice
forgiveness but you'll struggle to
forgive others until you can forgive
yourself yeah that's what I'm saying
it's like a reflection and that's why
when we look in our world it's our world
showing us us we're try it's to say like
turn the mirror around you're looking at
people you're seeing something about
yourself when you see someone that is
acting a certain way and like you're
judging it like I always use this
example but you know somebody's lazy in
the past I've always judged that because
I would never allow myself to be lazy
and then as soon as try you should try
it sometime and as soon as I don't even
use the word anymore now as soon as I
feel like now and I feel like I need to
be lazy it's now resting it's like now I
need rest like I need to coup I need to
recover I need to reenergize Y and so I
do it for myself so now when I see
someone else doing something that I
would have otherwise called lazy before
I don't see it the same but it only came
from me doing it for myself yeah I think
there's I mean I think there's truth to
that which is you know there's a great
Paradox about being a human right which
is every moment of every day we are both
individuals and members of groups so I
am me today but I'm also a team member
uh a
brother um an uncle um a friend a member
of a church a member of a community a
member of a team a member of like we are
every moment of every day we're both
individuals and members of groups which
means every day we're faced with little
and sometimes big decisions do I put
myself first at the expense of the group
or do I put the group first at the
expense of me and the answer is yes and
it's a debate some people will say no
you always put yourself first because if
you're not taken care of you can't be
there for the group yeah and there's
another school of thought say is no you
always put yourself put the group first
because until you take care of them they
won't be there to take care of you it's
a paradox it's it's it's difficult and
this is the Paradox of Being Human and
so yes we do have to do work and start
on ourselves and you also have to pay
attention and worry about others which
one goes first I it doesn't matter it
just yes is the answer and it's not it's
and it's not either or it's and and so
the schools of thought are irrelevant
you're going to have to do
both and sometimes they compete that's
the hard part it's like my team really
needs me but I'm really tired right what
do I do right do I let them down or do I
let myself down what do I do what do I
do well what do you do when you do that
cuz inevitably it's going to come up in
your life where it's out of balance yeah
I actually don't believe there's ever
ever actual balance I think there's this
is what we're saying about macro balance
this is what we're saying about Cycles
exact it's never in the middle uhhuh
exactly always like catching you're just
constantly catching it so it Cycles one
way and it goes back the other way
exactly and and the goal is not to have
a tip so far that it does so much damage
before we correct it the goal is to try
and keep it sort of you know trying to
be around the middle but this is where
good leaders and good people work
towards that bad leaders push it too far
the other way usually for selfish game
I'm curious if there are roles or
archetypes within business meaning
there's just like certain roles for
people like there's always going to be
sort of the boss there's the employee
there's the are there just roles that
people have is everyone able to be a
boss is everyone able to be
a so
the simple answer is yes there are roles
there are roles and we all play all the
roles right how's that possible the best
leaders are also the best followers
right the pope he's the leader of the
Catholic church and he's in service in
something even bigger than that right
and what you find is great leaders see
themselves in service to something else
so they're both a leader and a follower
and somebody who's on a team might
follow you know the cause of the company
or the strategy or whatever it is but
they might lead their team towards that
cause or towards that goal right so um
and sometimes um I've been in a in a
I've been with a group of like all hard
driving a type personalities and our own
in all of our own environments or
companies we're all the leaders of of
what we do so what about when we're all
together and we're in a situation where
stuff went haywire and one person on the
on the group like she stood up and she
was like she just just took charge and
she was competent and she was she was in
service-minded and we all deferred and
we all said how can I help you what do
you need from me give me a task and so
in that moment all of these leaders all
became followers
because um the one person who stood up
in that moment and was very competent we
now saw ourselves how do we help her
achieve the common goal that we all have
and so we all became followers very
happily and we all said give me a test
what do you need done
and so the best leaders know how to put
their egos aside and say now is the time
for me to serve now is the time for me
to be supportive and be a follower and
if you're in the Marine Corps the
Marines are constantly evaluating your
ability to serve and your ability to
follow um uh your ability to lead and
your ability to follow for example um so
you know good leaders know how to follow
uh and good followers it's when required
should know how to lead because you
can't just have a room full of followers
somebody's going to have to point the
way what I'm thinking about is how much
confidence it would take to do that so
what is it that it takes to be a good
leader like what are the personality
traits What are the disciplines like
what does it actually take to be a
really good leader so leadership is a is
a is an education right nobody's a great
leader there are good leaders but truly
great leaders still have room for
improvement yeah like there are people
that I think are great leaders but if I
asked them they would say I'm still
learning yeah all great leaders that
I've ever met think of themselves as
students mhm right I shouldn't say
there's no great leaders there's no
expert in leadership is really more
accurate right nobody's an expert in
leadership you can't get the 10,000
hours for leadership no but you
everybody you're a student you might be
a very Advanced student but every of the
great leaders that I've ever met we talk
about leadership they've never said to
me like how to do it I think I think I'm
done learning I think I know everything
there is to know about leadership
they're still curious sort of hardwired
in you if you're going to be a leader
that you're open-minded enough and the
world CH the world is changing and and
generations are changing and how the
world works is changing and so you know
the leadership techniques you might have
used 20 years ago might have been great
for 20 years ago they're not going to
work today and so a good leader is
adapting and changing for the world that
they live in so so I think leadership is
is a constant Journey um but if you ask
me so like what are the characteristics
of what does it take to be a great
leader you know Charisma Vision you know
I've known some amazing leaders who
don't have like big Steve Jobs visions
and I've known some amazing leaders who
don't have like insane Charisma where
they like they light up the room M when
they walk in but the the great leaders
that I've met all have massive amounts
of courage and I think when you have
massive amounts of Courage you also have
the strength to have massive amounts of
Integrity yeah and um because sometimes
courage is about making difficult
decisions courage is about speaking
truth to power courage is about doing
what you know is right for the long term
even though the short-term pressures are
overwhelming um courage is about
sticking your neck out courage is about
um um telling people that you're
personally struggling and you need their
help that's hard why is it's so hard to
ask for help that's it's
humiliating yeah because we especially
when we're judged in how quote unquote
strong we are or strong we look totally
that to say I'm not strong or I'm
struggling is is humiliating and there's
the fear that I will lose respect if I
tell people that I I don't know the
answer or if I don't know what I'm doing
and the great Paradox of life is
actually what gets people to trust you
ironically of course I know it's
annoying it is it's when it's being
honest with someone even if it hurts
them then the next time you tell them
something you're like good job they
actually believe you it's Simon cow
right right like no nobody no nobody was
like Paul Abdul was lovely but nobody
was clinging and hoping for Paul Abdul's
comment they wanted Simon Cal's approval
more than anybody else because he was he
wasn't mean for the sake of being mean
he was incredibly honest you know and
and because he's incredibly honest when
he gave you criticism deep deep down
inside even though it's stung you went
he's right and so when that means when
he gave you a compliment you knew you
knew that he meant it obviously you need
to have some level of discernment in
this honesty
but how can someone learn to be more how
can someone be more honest being honest
is really easy just tell the truth right
that's all that honesty is it's just
telling the truth that's all it is to
yourself or to others so such a hard
time because they don't want to hurt
someone's feelings being honest because
hurting their feelings hurts theirs it's
actually the truth is it's like usually
people don't do it because they actually
hurt more they they they're like I don't
want the pain because I know you're
going to feel bad and I'm going to feel
that so honesty doesn't have to be
brutal this concept of brutal honesty is
nonsense right okay okay so help me out
you can tell the truth without being
mean right also telling the truth
doesn't have to happen in the moment you
have to read the room here's what I mean
so first of all you're not allowed to
lie right so um and by the way to your
point it's it is hard to tell the truth
like Go 24 hours like we look at the
time now we add 24 hours right or 48
hours from now don't tell a single lie
so you know you're sitting there at a
restaurant and you're saying to your
friends oh this chicken is so dry and
the the server comes over goes how's the
meal everyone it's good fine fine nobody
goes actually super dry like we we just
told a lie like 30 seconds ago we were
complaining about the food cuz we don't
want to deal or somebody gives you a
sweater it's the ugliest thing you've
ever seen in your life and they go do
you it do you like it people love
parties cuz they can be honest right oh
my God I love it total lie right so um
my rule is you have to tell the truth um
but so for example if somebody gives me
an ugly sweater and says what do you
think I going go oh my God thank you so
much for thinking of me it's so good of
you to give me a gift I so appreciate it
you have no idea all of that is 100%
true you
know but I I don't have to say this is
the ugliest thing I've ever seen that's
just mean yeah like there's nothing it
doesn't have to be brutal it just has to
be true right but the one of the big
lessons I learned was human beings are
sensitive and we have to read the room a
little bit right so for example I went
to see a friend of mine's play in New
York and it was easily one of the worst
things I've ever seen in my life and if
my friend weren't in it I would have
left I was awful no there was no
redeeming qualities about it whatsoever
and at the end of the play I was waiting
in the Foye I was waiting the lobby of
the theater and she came out to like say
had her friends and family and she's
still in costume and makeup and her
adrenaline is still jacked up
and she comes up to me and she knows I'm
an honest broker and she says what you
think and I now is not the time or place
to have an honest assessment it's just
not the time or place and even though
I'm always want to be honest that
question should not be answered right
now and so I said oh my God what a
thrill to come and see you do your thing
I've never seen you on the stage before
it was such a joy to come and support
and be here and watch you do your thing
and and I om is I'm so glad I came all
of that is true all 100% true right yeah
the next day when the adrenaline had
settled and she's rational again right
cuz she's not rational in the moment
when she's jacked up on adrenaline right
right right if I had given her honest
assessment I would have got punched in
the face right so the next day I called
her up and said hey can I talk to you
about what I thought about the play She
Goes absolutely and I told her what I
thought and we had a really nice honest
conversation about it and she agreed
with a lot of the stuff and we we talked
it through and it wasn't but the point
is I answered a question but I didn't
have to answer it in that moment right
and so like we we do this in our
personal relationships right um which is
when somebody's in an emotional state
happy sad angry frustrated right and we
correct the facts of their argument no
no no don't be an idiot that now is the
time to hold space now is the time to
let them vent you know tomorrow you can
say can I can I just follow up on
something we we we talked about
yesterday that's not sitting with me
then you can talk about the facts when
when someone's in a more rational
mindset right but we're all like that MH
how does someone how does someone that's
uh let's just do business as an example
how does an
employee open up this line of
communication of honesty with let's say
a boss or a superior of sorts and make
it safe and how does a boss or a
superior get honest feedback like what
are circumstances that could be
um put in place that would be
comfortable enough for the receiver and
The Giver in both of those scenarios
okay so I do there there is an
expectation the that the person in the
leadership position should have more
responsibility right so I expect the
person in the leadership position to be
working on themselves and their skills
to be able to know how to do some of
these things so for example if you want
to create an environment where people
can give you honest assessment well if
they come and give you some difficult
feedback don't be defensive and don't
on them when they give it to you be
grateful and ask for more right so if
you if you create an incentive structure
where people are recognized and rewarded
and and and thanked for the honest
assessments you're going to get honest
assessments if you if you're defensive
and dismiss people and brush people
aside or attack them for attacking you
well you're going to shut it down right
there so I do have a higher standard for
people in a leadership position um to
learn how to listen to learn how to hold
space to learn how to adjust their
feedback style for somebody so for
example I like blunt feedback like don't
give me a freaking feedback sandwich or
tell me something nice tell me something
difficult tell something that I just
just please just get to the point and
tell me what I need to fix I'm fine with
it and so what I very often do like most
people is we tend to give feedback the
way we like to receive it exactly right
so some people who like it sugarcoated
they give me the sugar coating exactly I
can't stand it right so but the problem
is not everybody wants blunt feedback
yeah right so we have to learn to adapt
our style of giving feedback to the way
somebody else can hear it not for the
way we like to get it right that takes
work I expect leaders to be able to
adapt um and learn the different styles
of process Where You observe how they
act so you can mirror them you can also
just ask okay yeah I mean I did that
with somebody on my team I'm like look
every time I get try and give you
feedback we end up fighting it's clearly
not working so let me reset hit hit the
reset but can you tell me how you like
to receive feedback uhhuh and she was
just very honest she's like yes I get
very tense when somebody gives me
feedback if you I need to be prepared
that it's coming so we can either
schedule the time so I know it's coming
or if you just ask me like is this a
good time to give you some blunt and
honest feedback and then I'll say yes
I'm prepared and what amazing thing
happened was once I followed her system
that she asked for I could be really
blunt and really hypercritical and she
could take it incredibly well but I just
had to schedule it or or or make a
little preparation for it when and where
and and it worked great but I asked her
M like if somebody asks me how can I
give you feedback I'm like just give it
to me I'll just tell them so most people
know how they like to receive it and if
they don't they say I'm not really sure
can we try a few different ways until I
find out what it resonates with me and
you make it a team it's a team effort
becomes pretty now the the other
question is is what if somebody in a
leadership position doesn't have these
skills doesn't know how to create an
environment doesn't know how to listen
doesn't know how to receive feedback Etc
then what do you do that's a more common
and also more difficult scenario well in
those cases there actually are
techniques to have an effective
confrontation with somebody who may or
may not be equipped to hear it to hear
the feedback there are multiple
techniques here's one that I like it's
not the only one but it's one that I
like there's a a neonic to help remember
it's called
FBI easy to remember right feelings
Behavior impact the order doesn't matter
but you have to have all three right and
we've gamed it out with ones and twos
and it doesn't work you have to have all
three the order doesn't matter M so for
example um you say a specific feeling
you have happy sad angry do better than
happy sad angry right a specific feeling
you have that's better than happy said
Angry the behavior that they did that
made you feel that way and then the
impact that it'll probably have if that
behavior continues and don't do generic
things like you're always late to
meetings as the behavior right right
because then they'll tell you the one
time they weren't and now what now
you're in defense pick the most recent
one or most egregious one even though
there's 12 examples always be specific
so I might say to you for example let's
say you're always late like whenever you
and I make a plan you're always late and
I I'm not going to come to you like Dan
you're always late okay I'm GNA say um
on Thursday when we got together um you
showed up an hour
late and it makes me feel um very unseen
like you don't care for me mhm when you
when you showed up an hour late my fear
is is that if you always show up an hour
late for everything that we do I'm going
to completely disengage with you because
I'm never going to feel like I matter
that's the behavior that's the potential
impact imp the behavior was you show up
late how I feel is unseen and the impact
is I'm I'm eventually going to
completely disengage from you if the
behavior continues right so you can't
fight about oh I didn't I don't always
do that because I'm only talking about
one
and if you say that's not
true in other words you you devalue my
feelings what you do is you repeat the
whole statement and say I hear you but I
need you to understand that when you
showed up an hour late this is how I
felt you're wrong I'm just telling you
how I felt and when you showed up and
you just keep going through it and what
the technique is designed to do is make
the other person take accountability for
their for their actions it's a very very
good technique it's not the only one but
it's a really good one and I it does
take practice and I if you're going to
use use it make sure that you are
rehearsed in other words you know your
confrontation statement you're very
clear on the behavior you're very clear
on the specific example you're very
clear on the feelings you have and
you're very clear on the potential
impact of the behavior continues because
they might get defensive they might
attack you they might point out
something that you did wrong well you
were late on
Thursday right and you can say I'm happy
to talk about that later but right now I
want to talk about this one thing so you
have to be prepared to always go back to
Center if they get defensive and attempt
to Sidetrack it or talk about something
else so that's why you have to be
prepared accountability is uh if there's
one thing in my life I feel like the
most proud of that I've come so far is
is accountability um what what kind of
environment like and I do speak in
engagements myself and you know I'll
talk about the team atmosphere and how
you know there's so much more benefit
when people give each other credit and
they take account accountability for the
things that they do wrong and and so
what is it what kind of environment is
needed where someone can be accountable
for their actions and have that have
that accountability which I think leads
to it's then it sort of conducive of
it's imp it's implying trust which then
is more honesty which is then more
there's such a good ripple effect from
that so so accountability requires risk
right I screwed up right it's hard to
hard to say the way the easiest way to
shortcut to accountability is for a
leader to create an environment in which
accountability is
rewarded right so like one of my
favorite leaders a woman named Lori
Robinson um when she retired from the
Air Force she was the most senior female
officer in the history of the United
States
military and whenever she would take
command she would always tell her people
there's nothing you can break that I
can't help fix in other words I got your
back so just tell me what went wrong I
had a boss named Peter and tagio one of
the best bosses I ever had who demanded
total accountability but if he went into
his office and he he never wanted to
hear something went wrong right cuz
that's not always true what he expected
here is I screwed
up right and if you went into his office
and said I screwed up you never got
yelled at and you never got in trouble
and your job was never at risk he just
said all right tell me what happened
right and so because he created an
environment where you could take
accountability we did he created a safe
environment of to take accountability
and we realized we screwed up he would
he could be upset and he could be mad
and he could be all he could still have
feelings yeah but he would you know he
would he would help you fix it or he
would make you fix it but he would be
standing on the sideline going yeah fix
it what are you going to do right um and
so we learned to be I learned about
accountability and so when I no longer
worked for Peter I now had the skill
right where I no longer feared saying I
screwed up because Peter helped me build
that muscle and so when I worked on
teams where I would get in trouble I
would still say I screwed up right now I
think I think where we where we get
accountability wrong and you know people
hate the term vulnerability you got to
be vulnerable it's such a such a talk
about topic what is it what does it mean
how do we well I think I think I think
what we confuse is we think
vulnerability is a lack of confidence
just because we admit a mistake or talk
about a failing or talk about an
insecurity or maybe we don't understand
the information or whatever it is we're
not smart enough we haven't had the
training that we think that we confuse
vulnerability and lack of confidence
right so for example if you say so we
say you got to be vulnerable like oh I
don't understand how to read a p&l right
or if you say vulnerable um is
accountability right H I screwed up I
screwed up bad right now there's
vulnerability but there's also no
self-confidence mhm that is scary
right versus saying can somebody please
explain explain this to me I have no
idea how to read a p&l if somebody could
just explain it to me would make my life
a lot easier thank you total
vulnerability total self-confidence or
the other way around as well or or the
other example as well which is um uh oh
I totally screwed up this one on me my
bad I screwed this up I'm going to need
all your health help me put it right
total vulner total confidence right so
you can have vulner with self-confidence
and I we conflated the two they are two
separate things I expect you to have
confidence and this is where you own
when you
own the uh uh the when accountable means
you own it but you should own it with
confidence this was on me this was my
responsibility and I screwed the pooch
how important do you think it is for
people to know what they're not good at
I think it's essential for us to know
what we're not good at how do you know
when to ask for help so I love an Ask
adding the word yet because otherwise
you have limiting beliefs right um it's
like I'm no I'm no good at riding a
bicycle
yet I don't know how to read a p&l yet
yeah that's what I said before I started
my Winery I was like I don't I was like
a this seems like a good idea as I drank
wine at 10:00 a.m. overlooking the
valley and I was like but I don't have
$50 million yet can I just say to you
that when you're drinking wine at 10:
a.m. you're probably an alcoholic it's
acceptable in Napa Valley okay so it's
just a so it's a community of
Alcoholics it's it's alcoholics without
the anonymous it's only when you're only
when it's wine
season you shouldn't be drinking alcohol
it's totally acceptable to be at a wine
tasting at 10: a.m. I mean I usually
follow it up with when I'm drinking wine
at 10: a.m. which is totally acceptable
right it was there was kesas and fruit
it was for
breakfast um but the yet you know it's
that that reminds me of that it really
does how you just have to have a you
have to have some vision for it well as
soon as you add yet you allow for
possibility is that natural for people
or do you have to teach yourself all
this stuff is learned this is the thing
that I think is really funny what can't
be learned what do you think can't be
learned is that even a does anything
exist that can't be learned yeah I don't
think yeah for sure I think you can I
think you can mitigate and delegate you
can't learn it like nobody's good at
everything if we were then we wouldn't
need each other you know community so um
you know I think one of the things you
can learn are the things that you'll
probably never be good at right
like I can get better at being an
accountant I guess but I'll never be
great at it partially because I have no
interest you know and so it's really
hard to excel at something that you're
genuinely not interested in yeah you
know why would I force myself to do that
because even if I put in all the effort
and all the work at most I'll be
mediocre versus somebody who's got an
absolute p passion for it they're always
going to outperform me right right right
so if you if you have if you have no
love for something you can still learn
to be better at it if you have to you
can learn to delegate you can learn to
ask for help you can learn for somebody
to join your team who's really good at
that that you're not good at and you can
say when you say I'm not good at uh I'm
not good at being an accountant yet I
can say I'm not good at being an
accountant yet that's why I hired
somebody and now I'm great at it because
I lean on that
person you know so I think that
yeah you don't have to be great at
everything I'm I'm I totally believe in
the idea that sort of get you know if
you're passionate for something get
better at it you know understand
understand the things you're not good at
so you can make Improvement if you need
to or or just or a delegate ask for help
I think asking for help is the single
most valuable thing that most people
don't know how to do right right
sometimes they don't even know what they
need help with but then they also don't
have the confidence to ask for it again
again we're confusing vulnerability and
confidence oh I need help can somebody
help me versus I need a lot of help I
just need somebody to help me then you
have to want the final outcome more you
believe that that you need to you need
to have more drive for the actual result
of figuring it out then no no I don't
think having drive for the outcome is
what magically gives you confidence I
think working on your confidence is what
magically gives you confidence so just
having drive for the I think people
sometimes have insecurities but they
still want the outcome to be positive
they still want that outcome but that's
what insecurities are they're limit
they're limit they're limiting beliefs
um and all of us have them you know and
when some people say oh you're so
confident well it depends on the
situation like in some places yeah I
have a lot and some places I have none
you know and I think I think
it's it's
about learning our value and learning
what we can contribute and again I'm
going to go I'm going to sound like a
broken record but the single greatest
lesson any human being can learn is to
ask for help and accept it when it's
offered I have this Theory with um
people that a lot of times they get
themselves fired from positions any
position a relationship a job like I
think they
subconsciously know that it's not the
right place for them and they're not
happy and they kind of they get
themselves fired they're they're a bad
boyfriend Bad Girlfriend they're a bad
husband or wife they're a bad employee
they complain they do the minimum they
don't go above and beyond like they get
themselves fired do you think there's
any validity to this Theory I have I
think it's because usually when they
leave my example is is that when it's
over or when there's a transition
everybody's doing better after like yeah
I think I think that's not always true I
think that's sometimes true I think um
so I'll give you an example I know a
company that is a very nice company to
work for there everybody's very nice so
nice right and because it's so nice and
because being nice is considered a thing
you have to do nobody gets ever nobody
ever gets any honest feedback because
everybody's trying to be nice right and
so people go through their careers where
they're getting no honest feedback so
they could improve but they're not and
so they just keep not getting promoted
or getting moved around the company and
it destroys their self-confidence and
eventually they get fired because they
suck now was that that person's fault or
was that the company or their boss's
fault for never giving them honest
feedback to helping them grow and
improve So when you say people get them
fired I don't know I've seen people who
found themselves on a slope of getting
fired
because all their boss ever told them
was everything they got wrong and nobody
ever told them anything they did right
so did they do that to themselves no of
course not so it's of equal benefit to
get I I think I think people get
themselves fired of course and I think
people I think people in leadership
positions can create circumstances in
which someone will be on a path to get
fired yeah so there's there's the answer
is it's both how do you fire somebody um
generally I I I wait too long on purpose
like I I want to make sure that I've
I've given every opportunity for someone
to be coached for someone to learn to
have the feedback um for accountability
for support I want to you know I want to
exhaust every potential to to make sure
that I've covered all the bases and um
and then when it comes to the point
where it's no longer tenable I I tend to
have a very um onest conversation pretty
quickly and I don't it's not like so
over these years we've had a lot of ups
and we've had a lot of downs and we've
had a lot of good times together like
nobody's listening to that I I I tend to
my my I tend to say I think it's time
for change um I think I I think it's
time I I I I want it and I have to
believe you do too and I think it's time
I think it's time for change and I and I
I think you can we can let people go
without
destroying without destroying their
selfworth and I think very often because
these things are often controlled by
lawyers and lawyers want you to make a
case against someone and then we make we
tell them your performance is crap
you're a bad person you're a terrible
teammate and I'm afraid there's no job
for you so we we literally destroy
someone's self- worth on the way out I
think you can let somebody go with
dignity I think you're I think you're
smart I think you've been amazing for
the time you've been here and I think
it's time for change and uh I think I
think you're going to thrive better
somewhere else and I really want to help
you land on your feet um so I think we
can we can work very hard to let people
to go with dignity look it's a highly
High emotional thing and it's a horrible
thing to be on the receiving end of um
and so to do our best to to build
somebody up on the way out I think is
important but at the same time to be
honest about change is necessary do you
do that on a Monday or a
Friday uh I don't I don't I don't know I
think it matters I don't I don't I'm
sure there's day Mondays and Fridays are
so not even really part of our world
anymore given the fact there's so much
hybrid work going on with you I mean if
I I've never thought about it but if
push to think about it now Friday might
be nicer because you give them the
weekend to sort of sit in it what do you
think about the idea look when we look
at the landscape of everything going on
in the
world and how big institutions are being
questioned and are they doing things
right and um whether government or
companies do you believe that when
something is so broken or broken that
sometimes it's just better to start all
over than it is to try and fix what you
have sometimes that's not an
option like isn't everything always an
option well it goes back to the
conversation where this started which is
how much pain do you have to endure like
our our responsibility is to mitigate
the damage and the pain and could you
reset everything yes but every time
we're unhappy with our government for
example do we have to have a revolution
absolutely not right you know um
um I don't agree with that I don't think
everything has to be a total reset um
um you know just cuz you have a fight
with your your your partner doesn't mean
every time you have a fight with your
partner you you dump them and start
again you know there is something called
doing the work and I think there's doing
the work in relationships there's doing
the work in relation in in friendships
that's doing the work at work and there
doing the work in government you know
it's I think sometimes doing the work
people are impatient with it because it
takes a little longer but ultimately I
think it's healthier and more stable and
it's mitigating an unnecessary and
excess amount of damage to get to a
similar result I think actually a better
result I think you know people forget
for every Revolution there's a
counterrevolution you know it's new of
course there's it's it's it's Newtonian
if you push hard in One Direction you're
going to get a push hard in the other
direction you know it's it's just just
because people have a desire for
something counter an example of a
counter Revolution right now people who
cling onto the status quo you
know I mean you have to remember you go
back to the United States you know we
had a revolution because we decided that
we wanted a better form of government
and we' exhausted all possible Avenues
to get that government and so Revolution
was the only thing we saw fit and right
after we won our independence there was
a rebellion inside the United States to
go back to
Britain uh so there's always an account
to Revolution because there's always
people who are on both sides so
revolutions are are in my opinion a last
resort do you think that we're at a
point though where that's on the
Horizon I think it goes back to what you
said which is you can wait for the
natural cycle of things and for things
to get saw out of balance that it
becomes inevitable or we can interrupt
that cycle and make it that it's not
inevitable so do I think it's inevitable
no I think we have agency right we have
control over our Destinies and to Simply
stand on the sidelines and say it's
coming and just wait for it to come I
think is verging and irresponsible so
what are
these personal self-development
practices that we can do to get to the
point where we have have um comfort with
honesty with confidence and honesty with
um knowing who we are like what are the
things that you've done that help you
really stay centered or know when to
slow down to before you speed back up
again into work and doing things like
what do you do is there therapy is there
what modalities are used to develop
yourself into a human so that we don't
have to get to a revolution because that
it's all like it starts with us and at
home so what are those home things other
than just I'm talking about like real
personal ones not just to outwardly be
nice but what else what else can you do
I think that almost always the things
that trigger us are the things we're
struggling with okay so if you're
complaining that nobody's listening to
you how good are you at listening if you
complain that nobody values you how good
are you at valuing others you know I'm a
great believer that um um we should help
people who are struggling with the
things that we're struggling with you
know I think this is the core of service
you know like the 12th step of Alcoholic
Anonymous is to help another alcoholic
service you know think about your
personal relationships you know my
girlfriend never listens to me well when
was the last time you sat and were good
at listening to your girlfriend you
know um she never takes responsibility
well when was last time you took
responsibility you know and if you start
by taking accountability does something
remarkable um actually my girlfriend and
I had a fight the other day
and you know in very typical
fashion digging up dirt from the past
you did this as evidence of you know
whatever we're trying to say we all do
the same and it was obviously it's going
nowhere and um and I interrupted I said
okay new rules we're going new rules
right um um we're going to flip the
script because you're telling me
everything you're doing right and
everything I'm doing wrong and by the
way I'm telling you everything I'm doing
right and that you're doing wrong so
let's just interrupt this and flip the
script I'm going to tell you everything
I'm doing wrong and everything you're
doing right and then I want you to do
the same
and we did I started saying all right I
got this wrong and you really you really
nailed this and then she said that we
took turns and it was absolutely
remarkable W and I think flipping the
script is a big one you know we another
time we had an argument same thing it
wasn't going anywhere and so I
interrupted and said okay stop we're
we're blaming each other for things
we've done in the past and we both did
those things by the way neither of us
were showed up as our best we did do
those things but how many times are we
going to use it as evidence against each
other I said so we're going to go
through foress exercise I'm not going to
ask for your forgiveness and I'm not
going to give you my forgiveness the
thing we're going to do first is forgive
ourselves so I'm going to tell I'm going
to forgive myself for something I did to
you then you're going to forgive
yourself for something you did to me and
when once we're exhausted the self
forgiveness then we're going to forgive
each other and we stopped and we and
then I we did and I forgave myself for
stuff that I absolutely did and said and
she forgave herself for Things She Said
and did and then we forgave each other
and um and in that moment you realize if
it ever comes up in the future you can't
bring it up in the future because you
already forgave me um but I think I'm a
great believer in interrupting and
taking accountability and so when you
ask what do we need to do we need to
start doing the things we're demanding
of others do you think that our intimate
personal relationships at home do you
think that that can be
separate from the integrity and the
person that you are at work with other
people meaning do you think that the way
that you act at home let's say you're a
cheater um are you asking how conducts
their personal life is it representative
of what kind of leader they are no no no
I mean long as the list of great leaders
who cheated on their significant others
long you know does that invalidate all
of them being great leaders or does it
just make them really shitty
spouses you know I mean human beings are
messy and
complicated and um none of us want to be
judged by the worst thing we've ever
done and have all of our work
invalidated by something we did
somewhere else now should we be working
to be
better Partners to our loved ones yes
does that invalidate the work you've
done as a leader no but it goes the
other way around if you're a screw up at
work does that make you a bad spouse no
but maybe you want to fix that stuff too
if you're a bad leader and so the you
know we should be working on ourselves
everywhere I would hope that those
people do do that heavy lifting and do
that hard work and have those
conversations with their spouses but if
if we're going to invalidate the work of
a lot of the leaders in our lives you
know for how they conducted their
personal lives I don't think there'd be
any leaders left no no one in the
history book no one's
left what do you think is the most cuz
there are some great leaders who were
bad parents never around for their kids
the balance thing right you Bal you mic
scale it's like he's going to be off man
yeah yeah what do you think is the most
hopeful and optimistic IC aspects about
human beings that are conducive for our
Our Kind to exist on this planet for a
long time to come and there not to be a
revolution like what is it that is like
people have this inside of them and
that's what makes us amazing and that's
why we can find our way out of problems
we all have um a very childlike desire
to be feel to feel seen and heard and
understood and so many of the things
that we do whether we lash out or you
know speak out or whatever it is it's
it's sometimes um because we just feel
ignored and if someone were to give us
the time and attention to make make us
feel seen and heard and understood it's
amazing how open and willing we are to
see and hear and understand others um
and the leader is the one who goes first
I don't care who goes first we call you
leader because you took the risk to see
and hear someone else first and if we
can give them that space they'll do it
for us and the best example I can offer
you is an extreme example is the work of
Dian Dian is a baa winning Amy nominated
um uh uh
documentarian um a Muslim American uh
Muslim uh Brit uh living in the UK and
she made some comments about
Multicultural Society that went viral in
the white supremacist community and it
got so bad um she was trolled so badly
that the police advised her to stay away
from open windows and the way that Dia
responded was to move to the United
States and get in touch with white
supremacists and give them a safe space
to feel heard now that sounds insane
that they should be giving her a safe
space to feel heard but they never will
yeah that's the point that was her Point
she says if I wait for them to give me a
sa that's the aners the chances that
happening are literally zero so she went
and she made a document about it called
White Wright listening to the enemy um
uh or hearing the enemy um uh where she
literally sits down L white supremacists
she doesn't endorse them or affirm their
points of view but she does allow them
to she calls it empty their buckets so
she gives them a safe space to feel
heard and what starts to happen is they
start to trust her and like her and view
her as a friend and over the course of
time they struggle to reconcile their
racist points of view with the fact that
they consider this woman a friend one by
one they drop out of the white
supremacist movement so it's it's a
slower strategy but it works because
yelling at a white supremacist doesn't
make them drop out of the white
supremacist movement but giving them the
space to feel heard and allowing them to
see for themselves the The Madness of
the points of view right is much let
them go on that journey and and the
leader is the one who chooses to step
into that very uncomfortable situation
first and in this case it was Dia who
who who was the leader Dia led the way
it's an amazing thing to watch you see
it happen live fting doent and it's just
such an smart way to approach it you you
are an inspiring person like you really
like you're willingness to you cheer for
people like you really believe in people
sometimes
I'm not is that is that not accurate I'm
not all of anything right like somebody
said to me once they asked me a question
they said it's wonderful how you want to
help everyone I said no I don't that's
just not a fundamentally true statement
what do you I can't help people who
don't want to be helped I'm not going to
fight
people like it's just not a
fundamentally true statement I don't
think everyone's good there are some
there are some awful people in the world
you know I try and understand them or
trying to have empathy one thing I've
heard like Jordan Peterson talking about
I'm sure many other people have talked
about is just how important it is to
talk to each other yeah and how it seems
like there's constantly more and more of
a breakdown of this ability for people
to tolerate each other we talk at each
other we don't talk to each how do we
resolve that to get to the point because
when I go go to different countries or
meet new people or go places I'm like
everybody's good and everybody seems
like honestly people are nice and they
they they're doing their best and this
all exists and it why do we have this
judgment or thought that someone is bad
we just haven't talked to them enough we
haven't visited their country enough we
haven't seen enough yeah it's it's it's
it's it's as you can't make peace with
your friends you can only make peace
with your enemies right and so what is
the first stage of creating peace which
is sitting down and allowing someone to
feel heard and I'll go back to what I
said a minute ago which is it doesn't
matter who goes first but somebody's
going to have to go first and if both
people if both parties demand the other
go first well then no one's going so
this sort of the antithesis of this like
cancel culture correct which is is this
is this sort of the dramatic expression
of the lack of talking about something
is they just go you're done yeah there's
a there's a lack of there's a lack of
curiosity we've replaced curiosity with
judgment there is we're quick to judge
um and we we seem to have disallowed
people to be on their journey and allow
for Redemption we used to we used to be
okay we used to be allow we used to
allow people to make mistakes sometimes
even bad mistakes and we cheered them on
on their journey of redemption and and I
don't know what has happened over the
past 10 or 15 years that we disallow
someone to be on a journey of redemption
I mean we're paralleling a social media
time frame I mean we're paralleling a
social media time frame you know we're
we're a comment culture you know I I
mean I hidden behind I wish people would
just not write comments you know I you
know I don't know what the value very
often no one has ever changed their mind
from a
comment an angry comment no less you
know I like like I read reviews from my
books right I go and read the Amazon
review read comments I read the reviews
and when and when they're constructive I
actually think they're really helpful
when somebody calls me a neanderthal
that happened like you're just this your
book is stupid and this you're a
neanderthal I'm like what am I supposed
to do with that that's that's not look
at you're an idiot this is productive
just an comment like I'm an
idiot like but when somebody says you
know I think you've oversimplified this
thing I think you make you think you're
quick to draw the conclusion here and
whether I agree with them or disagree
with them I can actually listen to that
be like hm that's a good point that's a
good point that I can make my work
better from that so like shouldn't we
all be trying to help each other make
each other's work better you know
there's a great technique in in
Hollywood or in theater where you don't
give criticism you give notes I have
some notes on your script I have some
notes on your performance that's exactly
right too you get done with the take and
they're like ah notes yeah so notes is
basically I've got some criticism
exactly but nobody wants to be
criticized but we're happy to receive
notes so I think we should be more open
to this idea of giving and receiving
notes I'd like some notes please can you
give me some notes I love that language
I love using notes I have some notes for
for for this as have some criticism how
important is language yeah yeah notes
we're open to criticism we're not it's
the same thing a mantics yeah language
matters you said language
matters so is it safe to say being an
optimist that you're very optimistic
about what you see out there or is or
are we at a crisis point no we're at a
crisis point I mean just being an
optimist doesn't mean I think
everything's going well I'm not blind um
I do believe that eventually things will
work out the question is how much pain
and Agony do we have to go through to
get them to work out and I think the
work that we have to do as a society is
work to mitigate reduce the amount of
pain we have to get to to get to
solution and it starts by listening
listening Bill Yuri who wrote getting to
yes the famous negotiation book he says
it beautifully he says we have uh we
have talk shows but we don't have
listening shows he says we have peace
talks but what we need is peace
listens you know and I think he makes
the point that more listening less
talking give me an example of a
listening what would that what would
that what would that be holding space
like somebody Jud somebody somebody you
can have judgment but you don't have to
attack somebody for it you know it's
hard not to just simply have not have
judgment but you can try very hard to
replace that judgment with curiosity try
and understand their point of view so an
example is somebody who you completely
disagree with politically and instead of
trying to force them to see your side of
it or prove to them they're wrong try
and understand how they came to their
point of view to be genuinely curious
about their person in their life and
what their Ambitions are and you'll
probably discover that you have more in
common than you do than you than you
than you think agree and then as soon as
you can find common ground you can build
on that which is a good message at this
point because the next year is going to
be difficult
rampant I think we need to do a lot more
trying to understand each other rather
than attacking each other how could the
how could the political system if you
could wave your wand over this next year
of how this looked to be able to put
someone in charge that is the best
person for the position the way that
they've done things is that the way that
they should continue to do do things how
do we how do we provide a platform where
we really listen we really have the
opportunity to hear the voices of those
who want to lead us and is the framework
right for that how can that look so that
the best person is in position a we have
to demand it right so like I said change
starts at home so a we have to work on
the skill set ourself the the thing that
if I if you asking about politics I
think the thing that I lament is the
loss of idealism and if you go I don't
care what your politics are you know if
you go back to Ronald Reagan or John F
Kennedy both of them talked about peace
on Earth literally they talk about world
peace in their inaugurations like show
me a leader right now that talks about
being motivated by world peace right I
even talking about it now sounds corny
and cheesy right right and so we we've
had a distinct loss of idealism we we we
like to other each other we like to
blame each other we like to talk about
what we're not getting what we haven't
been given what somebody took away from
us but nobody's helping us see a shining
City on the hill nobody is helping us
see an idealized sense of the future
nobody helping us see a world that does
not yet exist that we can work together
to build what we're seeing is all the
wrongs and and
injustices yes true those still exist
but we completely are either fixated on
what's wrong or what has happened and
few if any of our leaders are talking
about what's possible and what's uh
where we can get to who's doing the best
job the Pope I think the Pope's pretty
good um I think he's good and as a
result he commands love and respect from
people who aren't Catholics even
atheists like the pope you know because
he speaking in idealistic and human
terms that you don't have to believe in
the Catholic church or believe in God to
to want to build the world that he
imagines you know I think that's pretty
good um I think Lady Gaga is pretty good
you know um who's Simon pick for
president no no no don't touch that with
a 10- foot pole no I just I to me I
don't endorse candidates yeah I endorse
a process I want the process to work I
want that's kind of what I was saying
like what's that process the process the
process is that I want to I want to hear
competing Visions right not competing
attacks so you it requires discipline
from those participating they're all in
the weeds they're all fighting in the
weeds and I want to see somebody go
above the weeds and talk about where
we're going not where we've come from or
what we where we where we were or where
even where we are but where we can get
to it's almost like someone is then cuz
there's a it's like there so many are
playing defense instead of offense which
is like where are we going lack of
idealism right an idealized world is a
world where we all get along we have
peace in our nation we have prosperity
in our nation that Prosperity is shared
and we have peace in the world and that
Prosperity is shared okay whether you
want to call that world peace or
something else you want to give it your
own words that's fine Shining hill
whatever you want to call it and now
let's compete let now let's compete on
how we're going to get there like let's
have let's an argument let's have a
debate on the path to get to that world
but we're don't we don't our leaders
don't even articulate that world let
alone the path alas Simon for president
please
no I've often thought that I'm like who
really wants to be president when we're
looking at those PE people running I'm
I'm not constitutionally allowed to be
prison anyway cuz I wasn't born here
here so I'm I'm I'm not even fairly
disqualified yourself I'm not even I'm
not even eligible but I have asked that
question many times to you know in small
Circles of like this is who wants that
job there are people there are people
that I that I know that I wish would run
for president yeah but do they want the
job I want Lor president Lori Robinson
to run for president but does she want
the job want Kevin Chilton to run for
president but do they want the job they
do not exactly do not this is the
problem they do not there are there are
good people who who I would who would
make remarkable remarkable presidents
right and they won't run yet right I
wish they would right those are just two
brilliant
examples uh I think because the way they
look at the system now right I think
it's it's that we we are not electing
idealists we're electing literally
politicians you know people who play
Politics the game of
politics politics you go well you know
there's Solutions out there thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want want to hear more please click
on the Subscribe
button